thank you very much
i'm very pleased to introduce our next
speaker this morning um
who is a postdoc at creed like alexander
uh university in aramaic and today he
will be speaking on the local
interaction patients on routes great
flow structure and continuum
yeah thanks a lot katie thanks for the
introduction uh and in particular thanks
a lot to you and simone for organizing
this nice conference and for uh for
limitation i'm really glad and honored
to to be here
um
yeah so thank you thank you very much
for this
okay so
right i mean as you just said so today i
will talk about
the non-local interaction equation on
graphs and in particular i will focus on
two main
aspects which are
the gradient flow structure and the
continuum limit in the sense uh
the graph limit when the number of
vertices goes to boost infinity and let
me tell you that uh so this is um
the talk is based on joint works with uh
francesco patakini uh who is in paris
andrei schlichting
from muster and dian's lecture from
pittsburgh which is who is actually also
here in in the audience
okay
so
let me start with
so i will start with a very brief
introduction and then i will go a little
bit more into into details so
okay the main motivation for this work
come from uh data science in particular
so as you probably already know so data
have the form of point clouds usually
embedded in a high dimensional space and
a very powerful way to deal with um so
with that uh in particular to access to
the information of the data is to
consider graph associated
uh yeah more precisely
let's consider a set x
of uh n points x1 x2 xn which are random
sample from a certain distribution
and uh so as you can see here so
this gives us our set of vertices
uh more positive in particular we can
also refer to uh to this set using the
empirical measures associated
now
once you have the vertices if we
consider a
a weight function eta defined on the
on all possible pairs up to the area up
to the diagonal we have um
so
we also have an information uh about how
these points are connected if they are
connected and how these points are
connected
and okay so taking for our purposes so
we consider the the weight function to
be symmetric and uh so this pair here mu
and eta defines uh for us an undirected
discrete with the graph
now
what we want to do with the graph in
particular so we are interested in
dynamics dynamics on on the graph
uh but which type of dynamics the
dynamics driven by
uh
some sort of interaction energy which
acts on on the mass which is posed on on
the vertices so
just to give you a better idea so here
so here we have our graph okay
now let's let's only look uh on the
picture on the left so
imagine that on our graph so on each
vertices we can consider some amount of
mass okay
some distribution of mass on on each
vertex now
if so as you can see here we start from
a uniform distribution of mass on the
graph now if there is uh some sort of
knowledge of some sort of um interaction
energy okay uh among the vertices then
so what we would expect is that the mass
is distributed over the uh vertices and
it uh it flows over the edges okay and
so moves around and in particular if you
consider for instance some sort of uh
attraction then what we so what we could
have for instance is that the mass moves
around and it concentrates in two
in two parts here uh colored by colored
by blue in particular so rather brighter
color means that there is more mass uh
on the vertex on this vertices okay
the particular this could be uh
meaningful because so the dynamics so
after some time the dynamics basically
could
could converge towards
meaningful
clusters
okay now just to give you
a better idea i'll show you a video
let me tell you that
both pictures and video are done by
diane
okay so we start with a uniform
distribution of mass over the vertices
there is some interaction and as you can
see here the mass moves
moves
around and
you can concentrate for instance in
two different points
okay
which are these
blue uh so blue vertices here
right so this is the dynamic that we
would like to that we want to describe
but let me be a little bit more precise
so what does it mean that there is uh
that there is an interaction interaction
forces uh among the vertices so first of
all the dynamics we are interested in
are those driven by the local
interaction equipment the local uh
analytical interaction energy which is
given by so this formulation here so
equation one k plays the role of an
interaction potential
and
uh it is defined on the edges and here
by rho x and rho y i mean the mass at
the vertex x and the mass of the vertex
y
so these are the risk at the level
now and here comes the first difference
with rd because on rd if you want to
describe a set of interacting particles
so what we have is that
the mass is attached to particles so
particles are moving around
but the mass is attached to the
particles okay and in particular if you
want to describe uh the movement of the
particles
so what we have is that uh the moment of
the particles is described by
a system of odes where in particular the
velocity of the particles i
is given as uh an average of all
the um
of all the forces of all the interaction
accepted by
the particles x i on the particles x on
the particles x i on the on
on the eighth particle
um
right
so
okay so this is the level of uh this is
on rd
okay
but now as i said on the graph
the vertices are fixed they don't move
so what is actually uh moving is the
mass okay so we're not describing the
movement of the particles anymore but we
are describing the mass displacements
over the vertices okay and so just uh i
mean on um just have an idea of so what
we have on finite graphs so basically
the equation that we would like to solve
is of this form so the variation of the
mass
at the vertex x
is given as
an average of all the contribution given
by the other vertices
okay and here i wrote the uh i wrote the
equation in terms of
a flux uh j
and here eta is our weight function
because of course we only consider we
only consider the the vertices that are
linked and not the ones that are not
linked or
or whatever okay uh yeah as you can see
here the flux is not
so what we usually expect i mean it's
not the
the product between mass and density
between mass and velocity but actually
okay so this is like an interpolation of
the mass of the vertices but i will go
back to this uh later in the talk so i'm
just telling you okay so this is
basically the main difference that you
need to consider so on the graph
the
mass is moving and not the point while
on rde it's the other way around so
points are moving and not the most
okay so
this was just to give you an idea of
what you want to do uh what uh what
where our goals
but
we want to do that
such a way
we could work on a general graph so we
don't have in general we wanna we also
wanna deal with um um an infinite graph
so
infinite number of points um and so
where in particular
the measure instead of having the
empirical measure we have just a general
measure mu telling us the distribution
of of the data and the weight function
data
now we want to do that uh such that the
dynamics are stable when the number of
vertices goes to infinity
and also when the um
they're also stable for the local limit
meaning that if i consider a weight
function so if my points are getting
closer and closer so what we expect uh
in the limit is to recover the no local
interaction equation on rd when points
are getting closer and closer meaning
that i consider a
weight function
which is localized
okay
now
so in order to do that what we do so
what we did we
set up a general framework in order to
deal both at the same level with uh the
discrete at uh and the uh the continuum
and in particular now
we have that rd is the set of all
possible vertices
then okay so the the cartesian product
up to the analysis the set of all
possible edges the weight function eta
again is telling us which points are
connected and how
and the set of edges is namely given by
the support of data so it's the set of
all pairs such that data is positive
now
since we um
we we don't want we don't want to only
deal with the finite graph
basically we replace
the uh the set of vertices with a more
general uh
notion and in particular set of vertices
now uh a measurement
okay
now
basically here so in also in the later
of the talk i will refer uh to mu as the
base measure
um
mu
selects
our vertices or if you want just part of
the words just some of the vertices but
the the dynamic that they want to
describe is how the mass moves on this
vertices and in particular so this is
basically provided by uh the probability
probability measures so rho will be the
distribution of our mass and it's a
probability probability measure
okay
the evolution of interest is the
gradient descent of the non-local
intellectual energy
where k is our interaction potential and
this is uh
is symmetric okay there are also other
hypotheses that i will that i will
describe later on now
again so let me let me give you a
comparison with the uh on so with
basically the situation on the gradient
uh space so on rd and not on the graph
on our d so
if row is a probability measure so the
so in the space of probability measures
uh the non-local interaction equation is
this equation here
okay where the uh the velocity field is
minus the first variable minus the
variant of the first variation of uh the
local interaction energy this equation
has been studied a lot by several
loaders i'm not mentioning uh all of
them let me just mention uh so this
paper by carrillo de francesco figale
loran and
2011 where
so basically you can see that this
equation is a versus sign gradient flow
for the local interaction energy
okay so
and now the question is simple so what
is the analog of the non-local
interaction equation on a graph
right
um
[Music]
okay so first of all let me uh let me
just uh so give you some
um some related works in the literature
of course the list is not exhaustive i'm
just mentioning some that are relevant
for uh that we used most for uh for our
work
so in particular there is this paper by
so there is this series of paper
different papers more or less published
at the same time by mass milk
uh cho wang lee and zou where they
they deal with um the deal with
diffusion equation on graphs and they
introduced the uh the concept of vases
and metric on a finite graph
in particular
then there is also this paper by erbar
where
he introduces the concept of non-local
buses and distance
and okay and okay there are also others
other uh papers which are of course uh
related
and
so
what's the
so more or less so the so what more or
less uh
the authors show in in these papers is
uh how to deal with gradient flows how
to define gradient flows for
relative uh for basically for free
energies of this type where we have no
local interaction and
um and uh diffusion and relative energy
now and of course the question will be
what happens in case sigma is to zero so
in case we don't have diffusion at all
so actually it turns out that the the
metrics uh defined above are actually
not suitable for uh no local interaction
energies and i will uh and i will
describe this uh later on in the in in
the paper
and in particular even if we want to
even if we want to consider the limit
the sigma goes to zero this is not uh
clearly uh is not clear uh anybody is
not well defined and this depends on uh
i would say also on the dynamic that you
want to describe on on the graph so
remember that we want to describe the
gradient flow of non-local intellectual
energies on a graph
all right so
first of all the nor local interaction
equation is a continuous equation so
what is the analog of the continuous
equation on a graph it's a non-local
continuity equation so
on our d
this is the continuity equation the
usually the flux is the product between
mass and density now what is going to be
the con the continuity equation on a
graph
on a graph so first of all we don't have
the concept of
gradient
so basically we have different concept
of gradient sorry so
first of all the gradient which are
defined here by
uh
nabla bar of a certain function
phi
so this is like the difference
of the function between the points
and
the divergence there
is defined
by using integration by parts
okay so we have one half because it's
undirected graph and then
it's a double integral
uh
okay
now
so
on a graph
the non-local continuity equation have
doesn't work as this form here
okay so particular we so the divergence
is in our local operator and it depends
on how
the points are connected so it depends
on uh the uh the weight function here
here for simplicity i'm assuming that mu
is lipic
now
the first problem is another problem is
that okay so the flux is defined on the
edges right so how can we then uh
how can we then express the flux in
terms of a product between the mass and
the velocity the velocity can be seen as
a jump rate okay so it's difference of
potential if you want
and it's an edge-based quantity
but the density is a vertex based
quantity so is uh the the density is um
uh it is distributed over the over the
vertices
now in order to define the flux the flux
is going to be is going to so will be
defined by the following product so in
order to define the flux we need to
interpolate
the uh density along the um
along the vertices in order to define it
as a quantity uh which is which is um on
the edges okay so we need to interpolate
and then multiply by the velocity now
here the the choice is not canonical so
it's not unique so you can you can
choose several types of uh of of
interpolation so think about uh you know
like arithmetic mean a logarithmic mean
geometric mean or uh whatever
but the thing is of course that here the
choice depend on what you want to
describe
now for instance in the papers that i
had i showed before a canonical choice
for diffusion on graphs is to consider
the logarithmic mean
but the logarithmic mean is not suitable
for our purposes because in particular
uh so what because of the because of the
singularity because if for instance
let's assume that we start
with a dirac delta on a certain am on a
vertex x okay so the initial
configuration is a direct delta on a
vertex x i have let's say that i want to
describe uh repulsion so what i would
expect is that the dynamics so the the
mass will spread over the domain but if
i consider the logarithmic mean so you
can see here that i need to consider the
interpolation between the mass let's say
at the at uh the point r and s here is a
zero because there's no mass
okay in all the other points and in
particular if s is zero then this will
become minus infinity and then we will
have
that uh the interpolation here is zero
so
using the logarithmic uh mean
will give so will give us that the the
solution will not
spread over the domain even if we
consider a repulsive potential just
because of the interpolation
so what we do then
is to consider
an upwind
interpolation so namely um
[Music]
here so
what we do is we define the density
along the edges
to be the density at the source
and in this case the the flux j so
becomes has the form of a gain loss
operator so at each let's say this time
i'm describing how the mass is uh how
the mass is changing and in particular
how much mass
the point x is losing or is gain
um
right and
in case
uh yeah so when we plug it uh into the
equation so this is the form of the
non-local continuity equation
that we that we consider
uh okay this is the the the case uh that
okay i didn't mention actually this so
rho
this is the case when rho is absolutely
continuous with respect to the to the
base measurement okay just for
simplicity but in particular since we
also want to prove uh we wanted to prove
a general stability results uh we also
wanted to allow the mass to be initially
outside the domain the support of mu
and so in particular so this assumption
is not needed but just for simplicity
this is basically uh so i'm assuming
here that rho is absolutely continuous
with respect to mu and this is the no
local continued equation that that we
have on the graph and we want to deal
with
okay
we have the non-local continuity
equation
uh we knew that um
we know that the
on on our d then our local continual
interaction equation is a gradient flow
with respect to the two versus and
distance
now
what is and as we said as i said already
uh before previously so what is the the
versus and distance that we use here in
order to deal with uh also to deal with
measurement solution
so
okay
we consider
we we took inspiration from the uh
bena mubini formulation of the
persistent distance in particular the
tuba sensation that has been already
introduced this morning uh both by um
uh mikhaila and um quentin marigo so
uh but here what we do we consider the
dynamical uh dynamical interpretation
formulation of the dynamic of the versus
the distance given by banana mobile in
particular the two verses and distance
is the minimal uh action in order to uh
in order to move a uh configuration of
particles from row zero to row one okay
so it's the minimal kinetic energy
now in our case of course this has to be
adapted because the the the path are not
the uh continuity equation the usual
quantum equation but the non-local
continuity equation and so i mean very
formally so what we so what we what we
can do
we can uh define the distance by looking
at let's say our
uh
version of kinetic energy on on graph so
we define the distance
minimizing uh minimizing the the
the minimal so basically uh minimizing
the effort in order to bring a certain
configuration of of mass
from row zero to row one on a graph
and this is
basically the form of the uh no local
transportation metric that uh with the
file and actually this is not the metric
but i will i will tell you i will fail
this later
right so the equation that actually we
deal with is no local interaction
equation which uh we denote by uh nl
squared ie
and so this means that in particular we
deal with a particular choice of the
velocity field which is minus the
non-local gradient of the first
variation of
the
interaction energy and this is the
equation
that we deal
with
now
rho as i said already
might contain uh adults and even if mu
is a big even if the the the the base
measure is effect and so we want to work
in a measurement framework
moreover
we need to define properly the distance
and in order to do that
we need to show some properties so for
instance lower semi-continuity convexity
uh
a compactness property and actually the
the benefits
functional is not jointly complex in row
and v
but what we can do we can define this uh
in
uh in terms of the flux and this has
also been done by uh i think for the
first time by dolbo nazari and uh and
sovereign where they defined
a generalized version of barcelona of
transport uh distances
right so in order to do that okay
we need to
uh we need to define the distance so now
we focus on the definition of the
distance
the first step is introducing easy is to
introduce
an action function okay
now the action functional depends on mu
so the base measure
the distribution of mass and of course
the the flux and it is defined as the as
an integral function here functional
sorry where the density the density is
um
the density in this case is this uh
quadratic uh function
that is lower semicontinuous convex but
only
for one only one so positively one
homogeneous
oh okay just to give you an idea of what
is i mean a better idea of uh so what
this action looks like
uh in case again rho is absolutely
continuous uh with respect to mu when j
with respect to the product measure uh
mu times mu
then
this is the
action that we have
in our case
this is pretty much similar to
the
so the action that we have in uh
um in the two verses and distance this
spot so despite the fact that actually
here we we do need to consider
the the interpolation between the two
points that's why the we have the
contribution
uh given by the positive part to the
negative part of the flux
all right
okay well we can immediately prove that
this basically follows from the
definition is that as soon as the action
is finite the the the flux takes the uh
upwind uh four so there exists the
velocity such that the flux can be
written uh as in tree
and the action becomes
what we had in the uh
we had at the beginning so we had a
couple of slides uh before in the
benemubrini formulation of the uh no
local up point transportation cost
and okay so this is the expression that
we have uh in case v is antisymmetric
because of course on a graph it makes
sense to consider the velocity is
antisymmetric
and right so this is important because
actually the the action is
is is lower
in case i consider antisymmetric
vector fields fluxes
or vector fields it's the same
okay in particular we can also prove
that the action is lower semicontinuous
and
these are basically properties that we
use
in order to then of course they uh
define properly the distance
okay
but what about the local continuity
equation on um so written in terms of
flux variables so
in terms of flux variables okay so this
is not so this is the usual uh
definition so the non-local continuity
equation in uh measure valued uh flux4
is
uh intended in a distributional sense
okay so it's a pair
row j a pair of curves rho j is a
solution of the continuity equation if
and only if it satisfies this equation
in distributional sense
where here so you see
the presence of the local gradient
and
[Music]
okay so
we need to make sure that this
is well defined so there is an
integrability condition and let me just
very be very quick on that uh so this is
always satisfied as soon as the action
is is finite
right okay so we have the local
continuity equation
now since we want to define the uh so we
define the devices and distance as the
minimal action
okay in order to bring a certain
configuration from one uh
distribution to the another one and um
in order to properly define order to
show us also the existing minimizers so
we could use the the method of the
directing the law of calculus of
relation and so what we are missing here
is just
uh a compactness
property and this is basically what we
can prove so
uh
if we have
a solution of continuous equations
uh sorry if you have a sequence of
solutions of the control of the nor
local continued equations then uh with
finite with finite action
then we can prove that there exists uh
a subsequence
converging to a solution of the local
continuous equation and the action is
lower semi-contains along these curves
okay once we have that ready to define
the uh no local upward transportation
plus cost let's say and then i will
uh
yeah so you can already see that
why i said it's not a metric
uh so the transportation cost
as already said actually is the uh the
infimum
of uh
the um
the total action
in order to bring uh in order to is
infinite of the total election over all
possible uh
path in order to bring one configuration
uh from zero to row one
okay and as i said so what we can prove
here is that uh
the infimum is obtained and this is
basically a consequence so this is just
uh this just can be proved by applying
the direct measure of factors operations
because the action is is bonded from
below is lower semi-continuous and we
have compactness for the solution of the
the
contaminated equations
now i will not talk uh a lot about the
the properties of the distance uh
because dan will do that in uh in uh in
the next talk
and i mean he will give uh much more
insights uh on on this topic so let me
just uh let me just tell you that uh
what we
so what is interesting about this uh
about this this course is that
this is not the distance because it's
not uh symmetric so it is a quasi metric
and this is actually relevant for
uh for the dynamics is pretty much
relevant for the dynamics and let me
just show you an example
uh already on a two-point space
so
if we have uh that row it's a certain
configuration okay of distribution of
the mass and nu is another one what is
the distance
between these two so what is the the
difference between these two
so here you can see the picture if we
place
row
uh on the x-axis and y on so sorry and
nu on the y-axis so this is basically
the value of these are the value of uh
of our distance
and so you could see here that if you
swap row and nu
the distance is not uh symmetric so the
the graph is not symmetric so you can
already see it this is very simple
because it's just on on a two point on a
two point space
so you can compute really uh
uh manually what is the distance okay
and this depends on
uh so as you can see it's on the on the
configuration of the
the two uh distribution
all right okay so now we have our
structure okay so
we have
the space where we want to deal with uh
the local the local interaction equation
so
right so just to just to uh
so to to to remind you so what we want
to do we want to define so we want to we
want to see that this equation
is a gradient flow with respect to
the no local
masses and distance that we that we
consider was a metric t that we consider
and okay so since uh t
is only a quasimetric
so what is interesting is that the um
the the underlying structure of the
spatial probability measures is not a
romanian uh it's not romanian but it's
actually finn's legend
meaning that when i want to um when i
want to consider a uh and i want to
consider a scalar product on the find on
the on
the tangent spaces actually this will
also depend on on on j itself so on the
on the tangent flux itself
and okay let me just give you
um
so just a few insights on that
so first of all
the inner product
uh is defined in the following way
and
apart from the okay so it's a product
it's kind of an l2 product between two
fluxes two tangent fluxes j1 and j2 of
course there is the the weight function
but what is important is that we also
need to consider the direction
of uh a certain flux j
now what is the then the direction of
steepest descent from
uh rho
so we using otto's uh
interpretation so we can define the
gradient
using the differential in the following
way but what is interesting is that uh
the direction of steepest distance is
not minus
the gradient of our function whatever
the entity is which is defined in the
following way
but is the tangent flux
giving minus the differential
and this is basically because uh if we
change sign here you could see that this
is only um
positive homogeneous and not negative
homogeneous
all right and then okay so with that we
so our so we could see
that our equation has a gradient so as a
gradient flow structure
uh where the gradient is precisely uh
the
right-hand side of uh our language
all right now uh how much time do i have
i guess a little more than five minutes
okay okay very good so okay so now we
have a great infrastructure so we know
what is the gradient flow structure of
the non-local interaction equation
now uh
what you want to do with that
so in order to prove
existence
we consider
evolational characterization
of uh
of of the equation in particular
let's say in the cdn case okay so this
is the the gradient flow of a certain
functional f
and
immediately from the chain rule
and integrating in in time
uh then using uh
using um kosciusvars inequality and yang
so basically we have that
a gradient flow
can be also can be also uh described as
a curve of maximal slope so in
particular gradient flow will be
the curve satisfying uh this equation
where here instead of inequality we have
the the equality
now we want to do that also in our in
our setting
and so we do that notes in our setting
and in particular
so we have
so what we need here is a concept of
first of all a concept of uh
product okay which we have is the uh the
scalar product that i just
uh introduced then concept of uh the
slope and the matrix derivative
and of course what is important is to
this to the is to have the chain rule
so the fins where product is what
already already explained
we can prove the chain rule
from the non-local continued equation
which will give us the product between
the velocity field and the certain
velocity field and another analog
ingredient
uh given by the
uh the energy that we are considering
and okay so here we don't have uh
coaches varsity inequality but only
one-sided cochise parts inequality which
is the one that we need anyways for for
the uh for the
the variational
capitalization okay
so these are the ingredients
that we need
uh we have already the finster product
so this is something that we can prove
the one-sided crucifix inequality so
what we need to do is to prove the chain
rule for the non-local intellectual
energy
okay and this is what we do
uh let me just tell you what are the
assumption on introduction on the
interaction potential that we have so
this is continuous
uh symmetric and in particular the
the non-local so the the interaction
energy has this uh strange lip sheets
holder uh continuity i would say in
particular is uh
lip sheets uh
slices close to the diagonal and uh
holder with exponent two uh far from
that
right and what we can prove okay so we
can prove the chain rule in our setting
so here i mean the proof is is rather
delicate and uh it is based on a
regularization argument
uh but in particular what you can see
what you can what you can take from that
is that
we do have the chain rule in our context
now once we have this
we
basically use uh so we use the the chain
rule the fact that uh
i mean so our one-sided cauchy-first
inequality
and this is basically the the so it
gives so this inequality then gives us
the functional that we want to minimize
in order to have the the gradient flow
so we introduced the concept of so
basically the what is called the georgie
functional
due to the idea of the georgie of
rewriting this um as a carbon maximal
slope
and
where in particular
uh so as i said before so for the
for the for the criterion case here we
had the
[Music]
the dissipation like the the
the
the norm of the dissipation right and
here we had okay so our metic derivative
but here so the dissipation
is
precisely given by
um
it's it's basically what we expect so
it's the product between the two
velocity fields so the it's basically
the the
the the l2 norm of uh
the variation of the sorry the gradient
of the first variation
all right so with that
the
no local so no local interaction
equation so a weak solution
of the no local interaction equation we
can prove that is nothing but
a uh an absolutely continuous curve
from time to the
uh let's say the
uh
the quasimetric space that we introduce
satisfying the
uh so basically um
um
attaining the value 0
for the functional g
okay now what about existence okay so of
course here there are several choices uh
one could
so for we could prove that minimizers
exist by direct middle of calculus
operation but we don't know priority
whether the minimizers attain the value
zero
another possibility would be to uh to do
some sort of jko or minimizing movement
in quasimetric spaces but actually what
we did since we already wanted to prove
stability result we show existence
with a finite dimensional approximation
and a stability
the stability result that we have is as
you can imagine at the level of uh the
georgie functional in particular uh
having a sequence of solution of uh the
uh
having a sequence of solution basically
having a sequence of gradient flows
uh basically will converge to again so a
gradient flow
so to a curve of maximal slope
and this is this can be um so and then
having this the stability property if
you want a la uh san diego d
then
so using a finite dimensional
approximation we could we can we can
show as a corollary uh existence
for the non-local interaction equation
and okay so the final dimensional
approximation is basically the system of
bodies that i wrote at the beginning of
the talk
all right just uh just to okay so just
to wrap up i uh i want to
[Music]
so
just have one slides about what we are
doing now so what we are doing now is to
generalize a little bit the concept
of uh
so first no local continued equations
and you know we also would like to
uh
so to see whether it's possible to
consider different type of uh
interpolations
and um okay so it turns out that
in particular what we want to do is
basically also to provide a concept of
strong solution
for the
uh here i'm calling no local
conservation law because here the
velocity uh depends on the the
configuration itself
and okay so this can be done with a
fixed point argument
and of course it i mean it only holds
for a certain class of admissible
interpolations
okay so yeah let me just conclude um
so
right so these are just a few
open questions and future work that we
would like to to do
and okay so you can find uh basically
everything that i talked about in uh
um so in these two papers the second one
is still in preparation but we hope to
have it have it out soon and yeah so
thank you very much for your attention
is something that is still open right
now yeah
so what's the
interpretation of the long time behavior
of
well what i what i can tell you is that
in order to have long-term behavior so
we should first prove uh in my opinion
some sort of um contraction
property for the for for our distance
and so this is also linked with uh i
mean the concept of
i mean
stability
of the distance
and also complexity if you want but this
is something that um
in the principal species is uh i mean so
these three concepts might be might be
different
and uh in order to do that we should
first understand a little bit more about
the jurassics
let's see
yeah but hopefully but
i mean hopefully what one can could
prove is that uh in the long term
behavior we will reach uh
two meaningful clusters of uh
uh too many from clusters on the graph
it should be
something
thank you yeah
so about the
difference between uh
0.
so there is something going on
which which
marks a difference between the upwind
i i would say that this depends more on
at the level of the distance uh
at the level of the equation
what uh
so what one so what actually what we
have also in the paper so we wrote like
a very formal argument we're taking a
specific type of uh weight function okay
which is um
[Music]
yeah so just
yeah data
so
i think the
there's a constant depending on time i
don't know the dimensions or i don't
remember at the moment but then you take
like the characteristic function
uh
of a ball
centered centered at the point x
then okay so over
uh like the the dimension like the
measure of the ball
so basically what one at least formally
could show is that
solutions of the local local interaction
equations will converge to solution of
the local interaction equation
but not for every
uh
interaction potential actually there is
also an example of interaction potential
where this does not hold this at the
level of the equation
i don't know